I think I'd been interested in writing
since I don't know I was 12 or whatever
I've always kept journals certainly
steadily for the last 60 years I didn't
know how the writing and science and
medicine could come together or if they
would ever come together but they did
seem to come together in the stories of
patients and case histories and I I had
an effect written my first book on
migraine before I encountered these
patients at Beth Abraham
I would recommend keeping a journal
period I hadn't thought of it
particularly as a happiness producing
device I mean I think for myself there's
always been a need to make some sort of
narrative sense and to describe people
and events and situations and feelings
and and I need to keep a journal partly
as a as an act of clarification partly
also because it allows my imagination
and fantasy free reign
but somehow held held within a sort of
framework but I just I hugely enjoy the
act of writing and I find it absolutely
necessary and I am whether it's keeping
a journal or any other sort of writing
I'm certainly unhappy when I can't like
so for me writing is a central form of
of of happiness not specifically keeping
a journal but for someone else that may
be sort of 'men I think I think anything
for something creative